everybody's going to post your stretch
marks and your tick coming out
aubry o'day has something to say to all
the haters
and the body shamers child
the 36 year old danny kane singer took
to her insta story monday
to shut down the rumors after some
unrecognizable pics started
circulating online claiming to be the
pop star
while aubry didn't deny that it's her in
the pics
she addressed the situation by posting
this selfie wearing a black
bodysuit and holding up a piece of paper
writing quote
it's so sick what people will do to a
woman's body for click bait
and that my lawyer needed this photo to
defend me against it
when is this industry going to stop
abusing women's bodies
and just in case you're trying to figure
out what that piece of paper says
it reads it is august 31st 2029 pm
i'm aubrey o'day this is degrading
i'm just getting eaten alive right now
the singer also tweeted about the photos
explaining that her attorney had her
take the mirror selfie with the date and
time
to prove them false adding quote i'm
tired of this stupid shallow abusive
industry
the pics in question feature a woman
wearing a bra top
and bicycle shorts walking her dogs who
look exactly like aubrey's dogs the pics
also compare the tattoos on the woman in
the photo
to aubrey's over the years aubry has
rocked
many looks and in 2019 the singer spoke
to e.t about her evolving aesthetic
i'll put all those like snapchat filters
and
wigs and like everybody loses their mind
like let's
join the new age now and understand what
a filter is and does to a face
take a deep breath what is your message
to those haters who love to get in those
instagram comments i noticed she went
private on instagram oh i'm just
uh it's a little thing called honey
trapping whenever you're in a scandal
you put your instagram on private and
you can trap like 20 000 followers a day
thank you for making my instagram
numbers go up i love you hate and ask
[ __ ]
you